you moved to New York City did you not I
did let's live here in LA so literally
they sometimes just wander in
accidentally on their way to Whole Foods
and then that's how we get it but you
you live in New York now yeah how's it
going uh it's good III had I decided to
move when I had my first daughter and we
we could I still have this fantasy
version of New York where you know it's
uh it's easy to live but I didn't
realize that you know you have a it's
hard to raise kids there yeah it's a lot
more work to here yes yeah
so it's dirty and there's a lot of
distractions and I moved to the East
Village which is the dirtiest place in
the city basically so uh I like recently
I was rolling like my my little girl in
a stroller down near a Tompkins Square
Park and you know it's there's a lot of
stuff going on and I have my cell phone
there and I kind of you know I'm trying
to pay attention and she's trying to
trying to play the mallanna soundtrack
so she sleeps and and I see kind of like
to homeless people fighting with each
other
mm-hmm so I stopped like a Good
Samaritan and take a picture of them and
I forgot that I was rolling the strike
forgot about my daughter and the
stroller kind of just like be lines for
the curb
well it's rolling by itself that's why
it starts to write and lock it you know
has a lock yeah and I didn't lock it
because I was seeing a picture of
homeless people fighting and and it goes
right to the curb and I'm like I I
realize I don't go right away and you
don't go right away
well no I'm like like ah I know that's
not good and like this picture is really
gonna be yeah exactly
I was in shock and then it literally did
like an OJ Simpson in Naked Gun like a
like a Norbert like like right into what
I call in New York puddle in New York
puddle a New York puddle is like a
puddle that's been there for two weeks
and it hasn't rained in two weeks and it
also has it always has two primary
colors in it yeah and I was like holy
[ __ ] yeah and I ran and I like picked
her up and she was totally fine
she looked like the toxic avenger but
she was like totally cool and I looked
up and the homeless people were taking
pictures of me yeah so she's fine now
yeah she's fine now it's fine now but
she's gonna have superpowers and I heard
you like talking about you big Trump is
it three years old from loud noise and
now I'm like oh [ __ ] now yeah I mean
protective services are probably gonna
take me away ya know that's they watch
these shows for that you have two
daughters then no I do yeah what do you
guys do for fun uh well recently we we
try to get outside but now we're
traumatized for that so we I I made like
a bucket list of things that I wanted to
kind of you know do with my kids and one
of them is showing when they're old
enough showing them the Simpsons like
you know I think that Lisa Simpson is
the greatest role model for young women
in the history of fictions and and once
my once my kid hit two years old I try
to keep her away from TV i what you of
course you only and then and then I
started i sat her down and we start to
watch The Simpsons together and she's
guy think she's kind of understanding it
too is pretty I was pretty young I did
ask her what her favorite character was
I wanted her to say Lisa so bad and she
goes the one with the doughnuts because
she loves don't she went for a Halloween
she went as a ghost donut she's obsessed
with donut a donut that died and it's
the ghost of the donut yeah yeah that's
very imaginative
yeah and frightening is the one that
fell in the toxic pool by anything it
might be
you